This episode was sponsored by Wren,
a website where you calculate your
carbon emissions. You can also sign
up to make a monthly contribution to
offset your emissions or support
rainforest protection projects.
Tardigrades are famous for their capacity
to survive. If you look them up, you will
be inundated with long lists of the many things
scientists have thrown their way to see if the
tardigrade will survive. We’ve made some lists
like those ourselves. Tardigrades on the moon,
tardigrades in extreme heat. You’ve heard about
them. We’ve talked about them. What else is there?
Well, here’s a surprising fact you might not
have known. For certain species of tardigrades,
like the one in the middle
of your screen right now,
you can tell the difference between a male
and a female by looking at their toes.
That’s right. The toes.
These tardigrades are called Milnesium,
and the males of these species have a pair of
claws on their feet that are shaped a little bit
differently from the rest of the claws, with only
one hook on each claw instead of the usual two.
But after taking a closer peek
at this tardigrade’s toes,
we can confirm that she is a female tardigrade.
Now, that’s a fun fact for us as we watch
the clip. But it does not actually do
anything for the poor rotifers that are
surrounding this tardigrade, who are currently
stretching themselves in and out of danger.
Around the tip of a tardigrade’s mouth are small
bumps that we think act like little sensors.
And when those bumps make contact with a rotifer,
out pops the tardigrade’s stylet—a needle that
pokes out from the tubular mouth opening.
That stylet pokes into the rotifer,
and from there the tardigrade uses a circular
structure called a pharynx in its head
to create strong suction. And then, the stylet
goes from functioning as a needle to functioning
as a portable, built-in straw that lets the
tardigrade suck out the inside of its prey.
You can see some of the bodily fluid leaving
the rotifer as the tardigrade’s stylet pumps
away like a beating heart. And when she is done,
the rotifer remains, like an empy coffee cup.
This method of eating works quite well for
the tardigrade, letting her eat quickly from
the prey that is directly in front of her.
But not all organisms come equipped with a
weapon that lets them turn rotifers into Capri
Suns. These organisms have to turn to other
methods to extract nutrients from their food.
This marine ciliate is called kentrophyllum, and
it came to James, our master of microscopes, in
a large container full of beach sand. On a normal
day, maybe we would talk more about its funny
almond shape that stretches as it swims around.
But today is not a normal day
because this kentrophyllum is
about to be overshadowed by a rotifer.
Now, where is the rotifer, you might ask?
It is inside the kentrophyllum, of course.
We did not catch the moment of its capture,
when the toxic needles lining the kentrophyllum
darted out and paralyzed the rotifer. By the
time we arrived, the rotifer had already
been ingested…but it was not dead yet.
You can see it wiggling and wrestling
at the broad end of the kentrophyllum,
causing the ciliate’s body to wrinkle and
fold in on itself. But it is trapped inside
of a food vacuole now, a compartment
that exists to break this rotifer down.
Sure, the rotifer can try and fight
against the walls of the vacuole holding
it hostage. But there’s not much it can do
against the digestive enzymes pouring in,
or the increasing acidity of its surroundings.
A food vacuole is a hostile place to be, and for
minutes, its destructive tools will go to work.
In the end, the rotifer will be left in dissolved
pieces to be absorbed by the kentrophyllum’s
cytoplasm, sustaining the organism that
was the site of its last battle.
It’s a lonely death for the rotifer,
with only the kentrophyllum to witness it.
Though I suppose now there is also us, sharing
and immortalizing that rotifer’s last moments.
And if the rotifer had not died in the body
of another organism, it may have
ended up like this gastrotrich.
Now to be fair, they did find themselves in
a very similar situation: they are both dead.
But the rotifer was eaten alive, digested from
the outside while trapped in another organism.
Meanwhile, this gastrotrich is going through the
exact opposite situation. It is being eaten from
the inside out, by a scavenger called a peranema.
Now, as far as we know, the peranema didn’t do
anything to kill the gastrotrich. It was likely
already dead, though we don’t know what killed it.
But the peranema is both a hunter and a scavenger.
Sometimes it can be found with other peranema as
they hunt down prey, in a pack of hungry microbes.
At other times, the peranema scavenges. They
are notorious for being able to
squeeze their way into whatever
holes they find to get into a dead organism.
And in this case, the gastrotrich’s exoskeleton
was the right combination of available, open,
and dead for the peranema, which found its way
in and decided to begin helping itself to the
buffet of dead tissue around it. After all, the
gastrotrich won’t be needing that tissue anymore,
so the peranema might as well make good use of it.
The gastrotrich’s body has likely vanished
by now. Perhaps the peranema will have
finished it off entirely, or some other
scavenger will have joined in on the fun.
Or perhaps, it will have simply faded,
like the rotifer inside the kentrophyllum,
its body eventually fading into
the world that encapsulates it.
But for this last moment, let’s remember
the gastrotrich in a more beautiful moment
under a fluorescent light, glowing in the
glorious purple autofluorescence of its remains.
Thank you for coming on this journey with us as
we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
And thank you again to Wren for sponsoring
this episode of Journey to the Microcosmos.
Wren is a website where you can
calculate your carbon emissions,
then offset them by funding projects like
community tree planting in East Africa
or a project that uses satellite monitoring and
drones to detect and prevent deforestation in the
Amazon rainforest. We will need a lot of different
approaches to take on the climate crisis,
and this is one way that you can learn more about
your carbon contribution and take some action.
You’ll answer a few questions about your
lifestyle and they’ll also show you ways
you can start reducing your carbon emissions.
No one can reduce their footprint to zero,
but when using Wren, you can
offset what you have left.
Once you sign up, you’ll receive
updates from the tree planting,
rainforest protection, and
other projects you support.
And we’ve partnered with Wren
to protect an extra 10 acres
of rainforest for the first 100 people who
sign up using our link in the description!
There’s a group of people in the world, and
their names are on the screen right now,
who really rather like chill videos about
tardigrades sucking the insides out of rotifers.
They are our Patrons on Patreon. They’re the kind
of people who think to themselves, “You know,
I would really like for this kind of content to
exist and so, they give us a little bit of money
every month so that we can keep doing it. And we
really, definitely, could not do it without them.
If you would like to become one of those people,
you can do that at patreon.com/journeytomicro.
And if you’d like to see more from
our Master of Microscopes James Weiss,
you can check out Jam & Germs
on Instagram or on TikTok.
And if you want to see more from us, I bet you
there’s a subscribe button somewhere nearby.